a new round of talks to try to end the
war in ukraine began this morning in
istanbul turkey in the meantime russian
troops continue air attacks on ukraine's
capital kiev the mayor of a nearby town
says it has been liberated by ukrainian
forces but the u.s cannot confirm that
holly williams and her crew found that
advances by ukraine's troops are no
guarantee of safety for the people
living there this morning she is in
central ukraine that's about 100 miles
west of the capitol holly can i just say
i'm very worried about your safety too
it's always good to see you this morning
to bring us the stories but i'm worried
too about you
good morning gail my crew and i were
we're all fine
ukraine says its priority at those uh
talks this morning is a ceasefire it
wants to evacuate civilians from towns
and cities that have been besieged by
russian forces
the towns of europe just north of the
capital kiev and trustee nets to the
east have been recaptured from the
russians according to the ukrainian
military
in many places russian ground forces are
stalled and taking heavy losses
the occupiers are pushed away from opin
and kiev said ukraine's president
vladimir zelinski in a video message
last night but he also said it's too
soon to talk about safety
that's exactly what we found when we
tried to visit the town of macariff
yesterday ukrainian forces say they
recaptured it last week it looks as
though this this area is still getting
shelled by the russians but as we
approached its outskirts
with
so the ukrainians are saying that there
is a drone overhead and they want us to
spread out to be less of a target
we turned back travelling at high speed
the ukrainians now saying four russian
drones were overhead
but then they ordered us out again
and into the forest to take cover
we're hearing shelling
there's one just now
many of makarev's residents were
evacuated earlier this month
everything was shaking like this said
one woman the planes were flying so low
we thought they'd shoot our house
but not everyone made it to safety this
security camera video reportedly shows
an elderly couple killed by russian
artillery
let's go we eventually left
macariff but if this is what liberation
looks like we go full speed full speed
do you copy ukraine's fight for freedom
may be long and dangerous
the russians have shown over and over
during this war that when they can't
take control of towns and cities they'll
still pummel them with missiles
airstrikes and shelling at the cost of
civilian lives vlad
holly williams in ukraine uh please stay
safe you and your crew thank you for
your reporting